[Music]
foreign
so things are getting pretty interesting
now we feel pretty comfortable with
solving linear systems of differential
equations x dot equals ax
by decomposing this into its eigenvalues
and its eigenvectors and solving the
system and we've seen some examples some
2D examples where we have unstable
eigenvalues somewhere we have stable
eigenvalues somewhere we have one
unstable and one stable saddle points
and also systems where we have complex
conjugate eigenvalue systems that kind
of oscillate or rotate in time
but most of the real world is not linear
most of the real world is not you know
small angle approximations of a pendulum
and things like that most of the real
world is actually non-linear when you
think about
um
you know Newton's law of gravitation and
planetary Dynamics or an actual pendulum
has you know it's not Theta double dot
equals Theta or minus Theta it's minus
sine of theta there's non-linear terms
and so what we're going to talk about is
how to analyze honest-to-goodness fully
non-linear differential equations that
are really nasty by finding fixed points
and linearizing zooming in near that
fixed point where it looks approximately
like this system where we have tools
where we can analyze that system so this
is one of my favorites this is really a
big step transitioning from kind of
intro simple linear ordinary
differential equations to starting to
build the framework and the scaffolding
and the architecture for solving this
you know much much richer class of very
non-linear systems
so specifically this is called
linearizing or linearization linearizing
a non-linear system
non-linear system
uh at a fixed points so I'm going to
Define all of these terms at a fixed
point
and one of the reasons that non-linear
systems are difficult is because linear
superposition doesn't necessarily hold
up here for a non-linear system I can't
take different solutions and add them up
and expect them to still be a solution
like I can with these linear systems so
we need fundamentally different
techniques to solve these
so
um what we're going to do is start with
a generic non-linear system x dot equals
f of x and I think I'm going to drop the
under bar just assume that these are
vector systems these are you know X is a
vector of states and this is a system of
differential equations remember
um
earlier you know X could have been the
populations of bunnies and wolves and
cats and dogs and tigers and whatever
like a bunch of animals and it was
linear and diagonal and decoupled if
they were all in different compartments
in a zoo
but if I have them in the wild in Wilder
in the wilderness now those animals are
eating each other and doing all kinds of
you know there's interactions and those
often manifest as non-linear terms so
for example
the number of bunnies that get eaten by
Wolves is not just proportional to the
number of bunnies it's proportional to
the number of bunnies times the number
of wolves that's a non-linear term in
this differential equation okay so uh x
dot equals f of x we're going to say
that this has a fixed point
X bar is a fixed point
literally means that it stays put it
stays fixed at that point if you start
at X bar you stay fixed at that point is
a fixed point
um
if
my function f evaluated at X bar equals
zero that's kind of a funky F sorry it
looks weird that's an F if my function
evaluated at X bar equals zero then that
means that D DT of x
is 0 at that point meaning that it
doesn't change in time there's no
there's no DX DT
because f of x bar equals zero so if I
start at this point I stay at this point
because it's fixed because there's no
change in time from that point
um good and so kind of in in a word you
know DDT of X bar would be zero okay and
so what linearization does is that we
zoom in to a neighborhood near that
fixed point so I'll draw like a little
picture here and I'm actually going to
show you this example later where
um in two Dimensions maybe I have some
dynamics that look
you know like this
and I'm trying to think of how to
actually draw this
um
maybe I have some system that looks like
like this so I've got all this
non-linear stuff I've got you know lots
of trajectories in this uh in this
system but I have a couple of fixed
points
I've got one of them here and I've got
one of them here so that if I started
exactly near that fixed point or exactly
near that fixed point I would stay put
there forever okay and so what we're
going to do is we're going to zoom in on
one of these fixed points we're going to
zoom in on a little teeny window around
here or a little teeny window around
here and we're going to pretend that
nothing else exists we're just going to
zoom into this little neighborhood
around these fixed points and in that
little neighborhood they're going to
look like linear systems that we know
how to analyze
so uh for so so this is a fixed point
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to say for
some point x
that is near that fixed Point nearby to
that fixed point
so basically we're going to say that x
equals
X bar plus a little Delta X where Delta
X is small so
um you know Delta x equals
x minus X bar is small
and so I'm just going to keep going back
to this little picture to help uh Orient
myself so if I'm at this little point
you know this is my point x
and this is my point x bar
and there's a little difference between
them this little Delta X here this
little Delta X distance that's a small
distance because we've zoomed into a
small neighborhood
for X near X bar meaning that it's a
little small Delta X apart
expand this differential equation this
is where it gets interesting we can
tailor expand this differential equation
and we get
um how do I want to write this so I want
DX DT
equals
f of x good so I'm just convincing
myself that this is true so
um so x dot
is of course going to equal f of x that
equals f of x
and that is going to equal f of x bar
plus Delta X and because Delta X is
small I can tailor expand at this base
point x bar at my fixed point in powers
of Delta X
um and so that's pretty easy that's
going to equal
F at X bar
plus the derivative of f with respect to
X and because X is a vector and F
presumably has multiple components also
this is literally
um you know let's say X1 X2 dot dot dot
x n
D DT of that equals then this F also has
components it has f 1 f 2 dot dot dot f
n and these are all functions of you
know X1 X2 dot dot dot X1 X2 dot dot dot
X1 and X2 dot dot dot this is literally
a vector valued function right there's
like a components to this function f
um one for the X1 dot equation one for
the X2 dot equation one for the X3 Dot
and so on and so forth when I compute
the derivative of f with respect to X
this is actually a matrix derivative
derivative called a Jacobian
and so usually we write it with a big
capital d f d x instead of little little
d f Little D X this is big DF big DX
because that means I'm going to take a
matrix of derivatives I'll show you what
this means in a minute but it's a matrix
of partial F1 partial X1 partial F1
partial X2 partial F2 partial X1 and so
on and so forth so this is a matrix of
derivatives that I evaluate at X Bar
times this is a literally a DOT product
because this is a matrix dotted with
Delta X I don't even need parentheses
here dotted with
dotted with Delta X
because Delta X is also a vector this is
like a vector Delta X
that's the first term in my Taylor
series
plus the second Jacobian derivative the
second Matrix derivative of f with
respect to x squared evaluated at X bar
again dotted with Delta x squared plus
you know cubic cortic and so on plus dot
dot dot forever and ever and ever and
sometimes we just say plus higher order
terms okay this goes on and on or you
know plus order
Delta X cubed and higher okay that's
another way to write it so this is the
Taylor expansion of my Dynamics my
non-linear Dynamics zoomed in around a
fixed point x bar
um where I'm only kind of a little Delta
X away from that fixed point
and so the key observation here is that
all of these terms are very small
very small very very small
if
Delta X is small
so if Delta X is smaller than Delta x
squared is Tiny and Delta X cubed is
minuscule and Delta x to the fourth
might not even be there might as well
and and all of these terms kind of are
approximately zero and so you get a very
good approximation of the Dynamics with
this term here
and then the last piece is of course f
of x bar is equal to zero so this is
kind of the only term
that's left in the Dynamics when these
are small and this is zero okay and so
what we have is that basically
um
and of course X here so we get basically
um
x dot is really
DDT
of X bar plus Delta X but X bar is just
a number it's like a it's a a constant
Vector that fixed point and so really
this is like DDT
of my Delta X so Delta X is kind of the
new state of my system zoomed in here
little Delta x d DT of Delta x equals
this Jacobian matrix dfdx evaluated at X
Bar times Delta X
and I claim that this is going to be a
linear
ordinary differential equation linear
ode
in Delta X and I'll now I'm going to
show you how to compute these dfdx's
what these mean and why this is linear
okay good
so this was a big step
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you how to compute these Matrix
these Matrix derivatives maybe I'll just
do it for a two by two F Vector field
because it'll be a lot easier but it's
very very simple to generalize this for
an arbitrary n degree of Freedom system
you know a vector where X has n elements
okay so
um
good
um I'm going to write that out for you
just so that you see
so
and I think I'm actually going to write
it right here so this dfdx
and you know what I'm actually going to
write it in general because I want to
okay I'm going to write it in general
and then I'm going to give you a 2d
example like an actual f of x in 2D like
this and we're actually going to pick a
fixed point and linearize so that's how
I'm going to end end this so dfdx for an
arbitrary you know n degree of Freedom
system is going to be a matrix of
partial derivatives
it is going to have
um
partial F1 with respect to X1
partial F1 with respect to x 2 dot dot
dot partial F1 with respect to X N okay
that's the first row of this thing the
next row as you may have guessed is
partial F2 the second row
partial X1 partial F2 partial x two dot
dot dot partial F to partial x n and
then you know dot dot dot dot dot every
row is the same and then the last row is
partial FN
partial X1 partial F and partial x two
dot dot dot partial F and
partial x n and that is literally my
Matrix of partial derivatives my this is
DF DX this is called the Jacobian matrix
very very important and here we are
these are all functions now these these
were functions and so their derivatives
are functions and here we're going to
evaluate this this is a matrix of
functions here we're going to evaluate
this at our fixed point x bar and this
is going to turn into a matrix of
numbers these are all going to be
numbers when I plug in X bar into all of
these equations okay so that's what I
mean be mean by DF DX this is literally
a matrix and that's why this is a linear
ode because it looks like x dot equals
ax with this being the a matrix okay
good
um I am going to
erase some stuff and then we're going to
write down a two-dimensional example and
solve it
I wish erasing that was as easy in real
life
okay so the example we're going to do
this is a really simple example and I'm
going to actually in the next few
lectures build up a bunch of examples
some of my favorite examples uh from
Newton's Second Law f equals m a we're
going to look at potential systems where
we literally take like some potential
function and we put like a bead you know
on that potential function and watch it
move we're going to do a bunch of
examples so in this one what we're going
to have is f of x and remember f is a
vector and X is a vector
and of course you know that's F1 of X1
X2 F2 of X1 X2 and I'm specifically
going to Define these two functions to
be
um x 1 minus X1 squared and x 1 plus X2
these are my F1 function and F2 function
I've chosen them to be easy on purpose
because I want to make my life easy for
this kind of introductory warm-up
example
and for this example you can read these
fixed points off really easily so there
are two fixed points of the system uh
where both of these equations are equal
to zero so in the top equation X1
basically X1 can equal zero or X1 can
equal one
and if X1 equals zero the next two has
to equal zero
that's a fixed point and if x one equals
one then X2
equals minus one so we basically have a
fixed Point
um the fixed points X bar are zero zero
and
X bar equals one minus one these are the
two fixed points in Phase space I can
always call phase space the space of you
know X1 and X2 that's just a an old
habit okay so the way that we we
basically linearize so we want to zoom
in to a small neighborhood of these two
fixed points and in that small
neighborhood they're going to look
linear this uh nasty non-linear system
you know away from these points all bets
are off but if I zoom in really close to
the origin or really close to this point
one minus one the Dynamics are
approximately going to be linear
according to that formula I wrote down
before
and so I literally just have to write
down uh this Jacobian matrix DF DX
and that's my Matrix of you know partial
F1 partial X1 partial F1 partial X2
partial F2 partial X1 partial F2 partial
X2 I'm getting a little sloppy you can
see but it's really easy to compete
these partials so the partial of F1 with
respect to X1 is 1 minus two x one
the partial of F1 with respect to X2 is
zero because this has no x2s in it
the partial of F2 with respect to X1 is
one that's really simple and the partial
of F2 with respect to X2 is also one
that's really simple so this is the
Jacobian matrix in general and now we
have to evaluate this Jacobian matrix at
these two fixed points to figure out
what our a matrix is in those
neighborhoods
okay so um fixed point one let's say
fixed
point one
is let's say x bar equals 0 0 x bar
equals zero zero
and so here what we have is DF DX
evaluated at X bar we literally take X1
equals 0 x 2 equals zero and we plug it
in here
and this Matrix you know anytime I see
an X1 or an X2 they're equal to zero so
this Matrix becomes
one zero one one that is the a matrix
for my linearization zoomed in at this
zero zero point and we can do things
like compute it's it's eigenvalues
um if I read these eigenvalues off the
lambdas are plus one and plus one any
Matrix that has zeros either above or
below the diagonal then the diagonal
elements are going to be the eigenvalues
that's really easy to show you can
that's a good homework problem for you
and so the lambdas equals one comma one
so this one is unstable
uh it's like an unstable source
okay good so that fixed Point things are
going to emanate away from it locally in
an unstable way let's look at my next
fixed point maybe I'll do this one in
Orange
so fixed
point
two uh X bar equals what was it one
minus one
again I'm going to compute DF DX
evaluated at X bar literally meaning I
plug in 1 for X1 and -1 for X2 but there
are no x2s here
so this Jacobian matrix is now 1 minus
two has minus one zero one one this is
more interesting now my eigenvalues are
going to be saddle points so I have one
stable
you know one Lambda is plus one and one
Lambda is minus one so I get Lambda plus
or minus one so this is a saddle
a saddle point okay which is kind of
cool and if I wanted to figure out what
directions were stable and unstable I'd
find the eigenvectors of this if I
wanted to know the eigenvectors
corresponding to the stable and unstable
directions I'd find its eigenvectors
similar for this
and I haven't done this in my notes so
I'm a little nervous about it but I
think it should be fine so now if I look
in my you know X1 X2 plane my phase
plane
I have a fixed point zero zero right
here this fixed point right here and I
have another fixed point at one minus
one one minus one down here
and we know that locally zoomed in
locally to this point
zero zero my Dynamics are unstable it's
an unstable source and because these
eigenvalues are equal I'm assuming it
kind of is just like unstable the same
magnitude in every direction kind of
like this
that is what this point locally linearly
looks like and this point uh is going to
be a saddle point okay and so that point
locally linear I don't know what
directions are going to be stable and
unstable but it probably is going to
have something like this where these
guys are locally stable and these guys
are locally unstable and things kind of
uh
I hope I drew this right things kind of
go in this orientation
and who knows what happens between these
probably something catastrophic you know
I'm assuming what happens is that um
maybe you know maybe there's some
Behavior here where this this these two
meet I don't know that's something we'll
talk about in another day is how do you
interpolate or infer what happens
between these fixed points with this
linear analysis all that we can say is
that there are these fixed points and if
we zoom into a really small neighborhood
they behave linearly like x dot equals
ax according to these Jacobian a
matrices okay so pretty cool that you
can really start to analyze really nasty
systems using these linear techniques
that I showed you before and one of the
ones you know I love doing I'll show you
this in another video you can have
things like you know I have a saddle
point here and maybe I have a spiral
sink here and so I can do things like
infer well probably this will connect to
that and you can actually start to
complete this kind of global phase
portrait
um you know you can start piecing
together kind of globally what's going
to happen in some of these non-linear
systems based on these these rules and
these linearizations okay that's all
coming up uh soon so thank you very much
[Music]